[Musique]
alors qu'il tour on va demander à maxime
guéri de venir sur la côte est
[Applaudissements]
c'est amiens qui pose la première
question alors maxime vous est
notoirement célibataire ça vous ne vous
en cachez pas depuis combien de temps
n'avez vous pas fait crac crac boum boum
ouh là là là là depuis un certain temps
moins de six mois vous savez je me
préserve pour la femme de ma vie elle
même temps vous avez dit que vous
n'étiez pas en couple depuis donc six
mois mais vous avez quand même un peu
attention il ya différence entre les
flirts d'un soir et les histoires
longues
donc j'étais bien la différence en vous
maxime un fait ça vous quoi bonsoir les
fleurs ce soir ça peut m'arriver
lorsqu'il ya un coup de coeur
et plus si affinités maladroit ceux là
dessus d'ollon pas plus loin ce ne nous
regarde pas nous lui poserons thème
quelques questions tout l or gilles
questions questions paraissent ghani un
journaliste d'être mal informé vous
n'êtes jamais pertinent sérieusement
combien de temps par jour vous passez à
préparer l'émission alors je me trouve
assez cohérent dans ce que je fais
d'autant que j'ai des gros travaux sont
derrière et si on veut répondre à la
question je travaille quasiment 24
heures sur 24
concernant la fabrication et la
préparation de l'émission je me bloque
entre hal et 15h et 17h vraiment pour me
concentrer travailler mais texte
appelait les gens recouper les
informations et vous donner le meilleur
de moi à chaque fois à bien
géraldine question question oui voilà
dis moi tu as pris la place de thierry
moreau en 50 et cialiste médias est ce
que tu comptes prend sa place à télé 7
jours
non je lui il peut conserver sa place je
suis très occupé en presse écrite j'ai
trois employeurs trail promedia plus la
presse pro pour la belgique ciné télé
revue et pour télé star les hors séries
donc ça m'occupe déjà énormément donc
thierry n'ai pas peur je ne te prendrais
un matelas place bref la craba
légalement pour la revue de ce qui
arrive pas de joie via la phrase ce soir
merci on l'applaudît %
[Applaudissements]